[Music]
no
the rest will stay here in camp i want
patrols every half hour
reporting directly to me you're here
what is he doing here i forbade you from
even breathing on that militech convoy
so you calling your friend
to do it all behind my back is that it
uh-huh
that's exactly why i had me come and
stand right in front of you
do you think i'm that stupid i am
starting to wonder
damn it to hell saul are you seriously
considering letting that basilisk
slip through our fingers i am put a
chance like this
a chance at what rotting up the job with
ever since this fight's grown stale
come on put some feeling into it no
this discussion ended long ago
the biotechnica people will be here in
an hour try not to [ __ ] anything else up
before then
i can't believe it look there he goes
off to paint the grass green
being unusually quiet what's up
i see no point in arguing with saul we
can't win
so given up of course not we'll take the
basilisk ourselves
then wait for saul to admit we were
right either that or to boot us out of
the family
what's this basilisk nonsense it's an
armored militech cargo panzer
junk from back in 2060 or so they want
to pedal it off to a backwards country
somewhere it can still pass as a
technological wonder
the militech convoy will take the 101
right past
us shame not to say hello
this basilisk worth another fight with
saul
yes a craft like that would finally put
us back on the right path
the family is falling apart if we fall
into this biotechnica rut no one will
ever take us seriously again
okay so you do want to go behind saul's
back
and drag me here specifically for that
cassidy ted carol and bob
also on board
and you plan to grab the basilisk cow
thanks v
having said i'd help just yet okay let's
go talk to the rest
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
did you try to get saul on board again
no luck huh no okay everyone listen
militech will transport the vasilisk and
parts distributed across
two trucks wait do i sense a quiver in
your voice
[ __ ] you the convoy will halt at the
railroad crossing on the 101.
we'll attack from behind then get the
hell out and away questions
comments motions
nice job sunshine okay i'm in dumb short
sweet and pertinent thanks first we'll
ride to the station
the train engine we need to block the
convoy's way is there
are you riding with us or will we meet
you there
riding with you excellent let's get
going
i think i heard a little shake in that
[Music]
that voice you did not
ah come on did you get your hands screw
you but
are you sure you didn't leave any tracks
militech won't notice the thing
are you trying to insult me bobby okay
okay
forget not even
let's go
nobody's gonna notice you gone back at
camp saul has no wish to see us there
anyway
the better to make a good second
impression on the biotechnica
your sour faces wouldn't help much
indeed they would not
the raffins what about them expecting
any trouble
it's all is he's posted sentries all
around the camp
how's that not right he's wrong in
continuing to fight the symptoms rather
than the disease
you don't miss life in night city
sometimes perhaps
i miss the feeling of having a new
beginning of freedom
but i also haven't forgotten the
emptiness the feeling of realizing that
means nothing if you're alone
yeah took adjustment on my part too
though uh never was completely alone
you had someone a true friend
jackie by name you would have liked the
we have next right
big bastard
we like it so much maybe we should just
hijack the train
let the basilisk go on its way yeah
then just drive this beast of the 101
there and back
saul would be on board with that
are we ready okay the militech convoy
will be traveling from night city to the
base where they're due to meet the buyer
we will stop it at the railroad crossing
all we have to do is shove this beauty
in its way
v any questions
plan to move this thing how exactly
it's old tech carol will have to hack it
then i'll somehow have to finagle
authorization from the control tower to
move it
towel looks inactive to me too now we'll
see to that
you and pan am just get the
authorization code
okay let's get to work
so
what are you two doing i'm finding my
inner peace before the storm well teddy
is just being dead weight
any of this goes south you know pan am
will be the one to pay
do you see us hanging around to dry do
you see saul letting us off the hook
while pan
am takes the fall for everything i'm
starting to like this kid ted
he thinks he cares about pan am more
than the girl's own family
i think you want to use pan am to get
rid of saul
listen fate do you know what makes a
good leader
not some cliched adages that's for sure
the ability to overcome adversity solve
conflicts within the clan
trout's efforts to undermine your
authority meaning you're putting pan
am through the nomad school of hard
knocks
breeding a good clan leader pan am
i was thinking of saul ham is a god damn
pain in the ass
it just happens that's exactly what saul
[Music]
needs
[Music]
well hello there have you come to make
yourself useful
nope just uh here to talk you don't
really know why you're here do you
pan am asked me for help
she came back to the fold sweet talked
mitch and the rest over to her side
but still she calls you
interesting isn't it
even if we pull it off saul will be
pissed
i can see his face already
how's it going over here fantastic we
have everything hooked up
and nothing works uh it works though not
reliably
v could you scan it because i am not
open to the prospect of taking it all
apart again
[Music]
capacitor is damaged third from the
right
hmm indeed hold on
let me swap it out
time to try it again
hey it works
thanks fee
need a hand of course but in your shoes
i would look for another way in first
what that was quick
the stairs it is then
we have lights mitch and bob must have
managed to connect
got a little help from yours truly
i've always been fond of trains and the
stations where so many tracks converge
[Music]
junctions yes
free like you could set off in a
thousand journeys all at once
so
okay here we are
carol what are we looking for
would you help me look sure thing
[Music]
not here okay it must be here somewhere
look thoroughly please
nothing here
nothing here
nothing here
nada hmm
well well well
got something good job
carol we have a card what now
you have to put it in the reader wealthy
the card in the reader
here goes nothing
it worked come look
little engine that could
v i wanted to speak with you
missed you pretty bad oh
well this means
oh wait just just wait this is not how
we usually talk
no time like the present okay
go ahead that was a joke
listen v i believe i know where this is
going
and not to your liking no it's not that
i also wish to talk about it just
not so openly my plan was to tiptoe
around test the waters then retreat back
into my shell
sounds like a plan what went wrong
it seems you saw right through me
didn't have a clue how you'd react
you're not the only one shooting in the
dark
i would not want to [ __ ] this up
so far so good champ because i've kept
my mouth shut up to now
the thing is i usually act before i
think
uh-huh noticed i know
but i also need impulses to act upon
when i do something spontaneously i feel
i'm being honest
yet with you i prefer to play it safe
why is it any different with me
because i truly care this time yet i
fear i'll do or say something foolish
and be left alone in the desert i would
rather keep you close
if only as a friend
try following the impulse next time
okay well in any case you've been warned
all right let's rejoin the others
convoy got eyes and ears on it yes carol
checks their communication channels from
time to
time everything is proceeding as planned
for now
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the convoy is already heading our way
hey jude what's up uh you know
family you
[Music]
actually thought i'd never hear from you
again after the
mico sich
re-watch the scroll from that day
you had no choice but i ain't calling to
rehash old ones
got a favor to ask
[Music]
ask away never boring with you
interesting people aren't easily bored
no chance in your company now that we've
blown each other what's up
you're on a need to know basis so this
particular mission don't require you to
have no gun
just a wetsuit
all right then count me in but i gotta
warn you
i look great in a wetsuit damn
outpass rancho coronado know it
sure what about it little uh abandoned
bungalow lakeside
meet me there at sundown
[Music]
okay um is this a date
[Music]
you're not my type homes just show up
i'll see you there
[Music]
you worried about saul
[Music]
you're acting spooked as if you're the
first person ever to stand up to saul
save your breath i don't need to be
consoled
was it someone i know new
scorpion you came home from the war
head full of new ideas and a host of new
contacts
he tried to get saul to lead us in
joining snake nation
it would make us stronger he said
i don't think he keeps a word of it to
me what did saul do
saul dressed the guy down head to toe
for messing with the family
hell he didn't send him on any jobs for
a year
gee really consoling thanks
you said yourself you didn't need any
[Music]
i'll raise a glass to scorpion
[Music]
to scorpion and a jackie
[Music]
i'm gonna try and get some sleep
okay it'll be quite some time before the
convoy comes through
[Music]
come on kind of cold out here
not true but this is nice
catch some jedi with me
i'll just lie here a while by your side
gazing at the stars is that another area
of your expertise
you got maps of the heavens in your
library
of course that's the big dipper and do
you see the small flickering start on
the right
[Music]
ah yeah you two
oh dear that means there's a major
league
[Music]
good night
okay here they come is everyone ready
let's ride fee
[Music]
get her up to speed
they're going faster than we thought i
don't know if we can catch them
on uncouple one of the cars it'll speed
you up wait
no coming in hauling take out that
coupler
we're getting
surround them as soon as they're cut off
let's
don't break works hurry up
[Music]
target
[Music]
go go
all as planned boss all right the
train's leaving
good better move
okay let's go ready to roll
[ __ ] it worked of course it did
just as i said it would
how's it going there me did you have fun
sure did just be happy you won't be
around to put the hunt
i can talk to him if you want no thank
you i'll take care of this myself
i don't believe i've had the pleasure
what's the meaning of this exactly what
you see
the basilisk all i see is two trucks
with giant militech logos on them
[ __ ] pandam you can see them from miles
away you think we don't have problems
enough on our hands
the raffans could rear their heads at
any moment and now we have militech to
worry about too
stop it [ __ ] just shut up already
do you want to serve corporations
forever fine
go right ahead in that case we'll leave
the basilisk as a souvenir of what this
family used to be
well you know what maybe next time we're
attacked we'll be able to fight back
as soon as i'm done with biotechnica we
call a family meeting to discuss this
discuss you until that time i want these
trucks
out of my sight and the basilisk can we
put it together
do what you want just get out of my
sight
bob mitch you two take the trucks around
back we need to unload
sure but then what do we do with them oh
i've got an idea
got quite a pair of lungs there thanks
i believe the last time i pulled
something like that i was 10 years old
seem to still be in fine working order
everything okay yes of course
though the great train robbery bit of
this was much more enjoyable
you need me again all you gotta do is
call
v i am sure i will so you'd better
expect that call
be waiting take care